[Música]
les doy la bienvenida a un nuevo
episodio de boleto de vuelta que en esta
ocasión nos lleva a regar una pequeña
ciudad en medio del sáhara argelino que
se convirtió en el escenario de los
primeros ensayos nucleares franceses el
centro sahariano de experimentación
militar se empezó a construir en 1957 en
ese entonces argelia era de manera
oficial parte del territorio francés
desde hacía más de un siglo el primer
ensayo de un arma nuclear ocurrió el 13
de febrero de 1960 su nombre en clave
hierba azul la explosión alcanzó una
potencia de 70 kilos tones es decir
cuatro veces la potencia de la bomba de
hiroshima faltan sólo 50 kilómetros de
la ciudad pero las autoridades francesas
aseguraron haber tomado todas las
precauciones necesarias para proteger a
la población en un año se llevarían a
cabo otras tres pruebas el regal donde
habría otras tres explosiones hasta 1967
casi 60 años después de la independencia
estas pruebas nucleares siguen siendo
uno de los principales conflictos entre
argelia y francia
argel todavía espera que parís asegure
la descontaminación de las áreas
nucleares y bendice a las víctimas de
las radiaciones
pero también a los actuales habitantes
de reagan quienes continúan padeciendo
las consecuencias de los residuos
radiactivos entretanto en francia-
antiguos reclutas que prestaron su
servicio militar en argelia buscaban que
las consecuencias de las radiaciones en
su salud sean reconocidas por el estado
francés las indemnizaciones ya
comenzaron
[Música]
el desierto hasta donde alcanza la vista
alambre de púas que delimita una zona en
la que no hay un alma viva una reja que
se abre hacia el gran vacío de un
enemigo invisible la radioactividad
causa viene conmigo si voy a unos
cientos de metros la zona cero de la
primera explosión nuclear francesa
nuestro equipo ha tomado todas las
precauciones necesarias y no debe
permanecer en el lugar más de 15 minutos
aquí estamos en el límite del punto cero
que es la zona contaminada cuanto más
cerca esté mayor será la contaminación
es así esa es la zona con más arena
vitrificada está todo libre y cuanto más
se avanza más se ve esa mancha negra que
contiene elementos radiactivos como el
plutonio el mayor riesgo es que los
humanos respiren partículas contaminadas
en cuanto a hacer con la sonda al suelo
el medidor se vuelve loco
más de 60 años después
la radiactividad sigue siendo
extremadamente alta en esta zona apta la
trabajo para el ejército francés durante
las cuatro pruebas atmosféricas
hemos caído en el olvido abandonados a
nuestro destino queremos que nuestros
líderes de hoy se pongan de pie y exijan
justicia francia
se ha cometido los mayores crímenes
la ciudad de regan está para siempre
asociado a los experimentos nucleares
franceses se ha construido una enorme
base a 7 km de la ciudad surgió de la
tierra gracias al trabajo de 6 mil 500
franceses y 3500 argelinos los peleó el
personal lavorante de los oasis abdalá
shalah trabajaron como obrero y
conductor nos reunieron como todos los
días a las 5 de la mañana
alfonso amor
nos dieron instrucciones como software
tírense al suelo y protejan de los ojos
el brillo de la explosión fue más fuerte
que la luna y el sol
ese día el 13 de febrero
y nos dieron unas instrucciones desde
tirarnos al suelo y cerrar los ojos el
mundo
sentimos curiosidad y observamos
discretamente para ver qué pasaba
los franceses lloraban se escondían bajo
las mantas se protegían con ellas hasta
que vimos y hoy nos la explosión del
concierto los dos hombres aún tienen un
vívido recuerdo de la mañana de la
explosión
en 1960 las autoridades francesas
conocían bien los efectos de las
radiaciones sobre el ser humano y el
medio ambiente pero el discurso fue
tranquilizador y no hay peligro incluso
la esposa del comandante de la base de
regan lo dijo puede vivir con sus hijos
así que no hay peligro para usted o no
no hay ningún peligro y mi marido
insistió en que estaba allí en el
momento de la explosión para demostrar
que no había ningún peligro porque una
función
gerard te la acc también estuvo entregan
como recluta durante la operación hierba
azul contó mucho su historia demasiado
debilitado por varios cánceres le cuesta
hablar su mujer que lo ha apoyado en su
lucha durante años conoce su historia
mejor que él
mi fuerza uach activó la operación y
actualmente se ha sometido a 30
operaciones faciales
la lefa andando en eleven no se puede
ver porque la cirugía también es
estética en diciembre tuvo cáncer en el
labio a legua
el agua y en 2020 se ha sometido a
cuatro operaciones faciales en las 2 100
es en el mentón y en el labio que la
ponía ahora tiene un grano de un mando
militar yo fertility de permanencias
yugular unos días después de la primera
explosión como era conductor y estaba de
servicio ese día un oficial le pidió que
llevara a otro oficial a donde le dijera
a un médico lo tapó france y pensé que
lo indicó el camino y entraron en el
agujero de la bomba colocando la bandera
francesa en la zona sea muñequita lic y
pactó un helicóptero la sobrevoló y les
pidió que se fueran cuando llegaron a
casa pasaron por la descontaminación
tenían radioactividad en el pelo y
consacá porque cuando regresó a francia
perdía mucho pelo
digamos que en aquel momento estaba
orgulloso en aquella época nos sentíamos
orgullosos
y las fans haber servido a francia era
la grandeza de francia city la cantera
fans
llorar de la que fue uno de los primeros
en ser indemnizado por el estado tras
años de incesante lucha
especialmente por parte de la asociación
de veteranos de pruebas nucleares
[Música]
hay personas que nos escriben esto es lo
que hicimos
pusimos en contacto con está vital si
esta es una historia de alguien que
testifican y neiker añadir y que oye
esta es una historia de la polinesia
sola purines y
voy a estar
así es como salimos adelante en 20 años
la asociación ha conseguido convertirse
en un interlocutor esencial para las
autoridades gracias a sus poderosos
relevos políticos y mediáticos en 2010
la ley morán abrió la posibilidad de
indemnizar a determinados veteranos y ya
no corresponderá a la víctima demostrar
que su enfermedad está relacionada con
las pruebas nucleares y si está lista
sino que será el estado quien debe
impugnar o contradecir esta afirmación
si la compensación se ha acelerado desde
2018 pero para la asociación aún quedan
muchas batallas por librar actualmente
estamos trabajando en varios temas un
cabal debo solo en primer lugar estamos
trabajando en el reconocimiento continuo
de los veteranos contra bloody valentine
con la ampliación del cuadro de
enfermedades la de salud y luego
trabajamos en la descendencia porque
estamos firmemente convencidos de que
hemos transmitido que se está realizando
una encuesta entre los hijos de los
veteranos con estos ahora pedimos el
pleno reconocimiento de los
derechohabientes sobre él y conseguimos
con un efecto dominó y crochet
le puse la esposa o la mujer que existía
a su marido que desgraciadamente a mí no
enviudada y los hijos que también lo
sufrían
decenas de veteranos franceses han sido
indemnizados sólo un argelino mientras
que la ley morán también incluye a las
poblaciones del sahara entregan muchos
de los ancianos podrían afirmar haber
recibido una reparación pero tendrían
que ser conscientes de ello los casos
raros son rechazados por falta de
documentos y pruebas muchas personas
están convencidas de que la energía
nuclear es la causa de todos sus
problemas así el año de explosión
atómica en hammond ya con una
discapacidad
hasta los siete u ocho años
un solo podría desplazarme en 41 cuando
tuve que hacer rehabilitación
para poder caminar al día siguiente de
la explosión el ejército francés vino al
pueblo para comprobar si seguíamos vivos
nos dijeron que están vivos deben tener
un buen curandero aquí estamos vivos
pero sufrimos desde entonces
todos tenemos complicaciones de salud
tengo 18 años y pueden ver el estado en
el que me encuentro mi pierna empezó a
hincharse en cuanto empecé a desplazarme
no sé lo que es fui a los hospitales de
regan atrás y otros lugares sin
resultados este mal no tiene cura
[Aplausos]
pasé 10 años de mi vida en tamanrasset
durante este periodo me di cuenta de que
había mucho cáncer en la región y en
particular sufría un cáncer de tiroides
de seno y de piel
estas fueron las cosas que vi con un
porcentaje menor al norte sabe quién
puso paso hua o no eso respecto al
cáncer y hay otro aspecto que son las
malformaciones sí de malformación por no
hablar de las malformaciones ortopédicas
[Música]
los experimentos franceses en el sáhara
sirvieron para preparar una guerra
nuclear sin importar el costo humano
aunque el discurso oficial del momento
niega la evidencia
creo en general que los experimentos de
regan no tenían un propósito
principalmente militar es cierto
el gobierno francés quería que estos
experimentos fueran útiles no sólo en el
ámbito militar
sino también en lo humano realizando
experimentos para saber hasta qué punto
se podía proteger al hombre
contra este nuevo peligro a tomás
para la última prueba atmosférica
francesa hierba verde se trajeron
tanques y tropas desde alemania para
exponerlos a la bomba y observar los
efectos de la radiación en máquinas y
hombres
cristian google fue uno de esos autores
donde el tanque fue girado en la
dirección opuesta pusimos la parte
trasera del tanque hacia la bomba
nuestros cinco tanques estaban allí y
entonces fue al volante fuego a
discreción durante varios segundos
subimos un ruido y luego el tanque de 44
toneladas retrocedió 2 metros que hasta
milán nos preguntaron si todo estaba
bien dentro o youtube doumet entonces
nos dijeron que estaban haciendo las
maniobras para ver la radiación a la
izquierda a la derecha atrás
hicimos esto durante 23 horas
una vez que salimos del tanque tuvieron
que descontaminar los de contamina
[Aplausos]
como pueden
con el único
por culpa de gol somos conejillos de
indias nucleares
hay gente voluntaria que cobra por ello
y todavía así no entiendo esto
me gustaría saber si mis amigos están
muertos si ya me entristece
[Música]
tras la última prueba atmosférica
francia negociará en el marco de los
acuerdos de paz de viano la posibilidad
de continuar sus experimentos tras la
independencia en el corazón de las
montañas de ineter
pruebas subterráneas presentadas como
menos peligrosas pero que conocerán
episodios trágicos el secreto de estado
sigue impidiendo el acceso a todas las
pruebas de contaminación de la población
y del medio ambiente que es lo que me
gustaría es que nos devolvieran los
archivos de la red porque la historia de
argelia y de francia y su patria es una
historia común invitación y se fueron
precipitadamente
en medio de un debacle radioactive y
tuvieron que enterrar todos los
dispositivos radioactivos en suelo
argelino
tenemos aviones tenemos tanques tenemos
barcos tenemos artillería la pedir el
plan de enterramiento de los residuos
nucleares bajo es nuestro derecho edward
y de francia debe cooperar y ayudar con
medios financieros técnicos y
científicos es cierto que mucha gente
piensa que los argelinos quieren dinero
que son codiciosos no es verdad no somos
codiciosos nos gustaría una reparación
espacio
la región de regan fue contaminada por
las pruebas nucleares en algunas zonas
la radiactividad no empezará a disminuir
hasta dentro de 24 mil años a principios
de 2021 el cielo de la ciudad de lyon
adquirió colores ocres más de 60 años
después del inicio de las pruebas
nucleares
las partículas radiactivas cargadas de
cesio-137 han llegado a francia
arrastradas por los fuertes vientos del
sáhara como un punzante recuerdo de la
historia
llegamos al final de este boleto de
vuelta a regar los invito a visitar
nuestra página web france24 puntocom
donde podrá ver este y otros contenidos
en español hasta pronto